[Música]
meus olhos não cabem nos seus quando as
fronteiras interrogam a nossa humanidade
você já percebeu que as fronteiras
interrogam a nossa humanidade
é como estar diante de uma paisagem
inigma tica e desejar saber como ela é
qual a fronteira que interroga sua
humanidade
o limite que interroga minha humanidade
é quem sou eu sou um menino que sonha em
ser menina e acorda no corpo de menina e
viveu entre dois ser o que representa
ser ou ser o que sente ser mas que
interrogada minha humanidade foi a
firmada pelas mulheres da minha família
sim você é uma menina
por isso você não pode jogar bola você
não pode sentar de pernas abertas
você não pode acarinhar o buço você não
pode não pode
meus olhos não cabiam nas pessoas que me
cercava e os olhares dirigidos a mim
sempre foram de repreensão não e vigia
eu pensava deve haver uma forma de
controlar meu comportamento para evitar
esse sentimento de estranhamento
quanto mais eu me esforçava para ser
amado e aceito mais invisível eu me
tornava meus olhos não cabe naquelas
pessoas e eu também não cabe em mim mas
parece-me que meu pai me vir
de tempos em tempos ele me possibilitava
a ser quem eu sou
a senha era essa aí é minha moleque eu
saí a molecada pela vida
coisa boa quando eu paro pra lembrar
disso
é incrível ainda após sentir o
sentimento daquele momento plenitude mas
eram só momentos logo depois voltavam
decifra me ou devoro ante a chegada da
adolescência a minha humanidade se
tornou terra de ninguém ea voz que
ecoava na fronteira ainda era quem eu
sou quem sou eu porque que eu não me
sinto bem porque eu não sinto
representar o que representa que a
harmonia que torpor voz na trincheira
insistir
você é uma menina
eu não me sentia assim eu sabia o que eu
não era recebia mas eu não tinha força
para buscar a ser quem eu sou e na
dúvida a potência a linha entre abster
se desejar viver é muito tempo nos
interroga nos convida a fazer a
travessia
sim é isso mesmo que talvez vocês
estejam cogitando tipo ame este corpo de
menina ou deixo um ok do outro lado será
que lá eu poderia ser um menino que sou
vai saber na dúvida eu resolvi ficar na
trincheira paralelo à s de ação comum as
pessoas humanas como eu tenho
preconceito que esse barqueiro que com
dos homossexuais transexuais e
trangêneros a fazer esse tipo de
travessia
pesquisas feitas por uma ong chamada
grupo dignidade aponta que a chance de
uma pessoa que se declara homossexual
transexual transgénero fazer e cometer
suicídio ou seja fazer esse tipo de
travessia é cinco vezes maior do que de
uma pessoa é heterossexual
o brasil por exemplo é o país mais
transfóbico do mundo 50%
o total de casos de transfobia letal
ocorre no brasil
em meio a esse cenário nada acolhedor
eu segui minha caminhada travestido e
invisível
chegando na fase adulta adulterado
travestido de mulher travestido de na
área tornei-me professor universitário
em uma das melhores universidades
privadas deste país
foi num ambiente acadêmico que eu tive a
oportunidade de espiar a vida para fora
da trincheira
o que vi outros seres humanos iguais a
mim e agora o que eu faço o que o
professor formador de formadores faço
como eu posso amenizar essa espécie de
humano fobia
você sabe que a homofobia é um
sentimento de repulsa a tudo que alma
vivemos um período em que tudo o que é
humano é estranho ao ano
estamos preocupados em formar homens e
mulheres não pessoas humanas o que a
pessoa humana a pessoa humana é
aguerrida e amável é forte e frágil e
vulnerável e corajosa
tudo isso ao mesmo tempo agora porque
todas as contrariedades são
complementares
o espaço acadêmico me possibilitou eu me
despir da área à medida que as pessoas
reconheciam o meu trabalho e reconheciam
profissionalmente a qualidade dele e eu
ia ficando mais relaxado ia me
despedindo da área
parei de usar brincos anéis aqueles
malditos scarpa ans eo e pouco a pouco
foi aparecendo pouco a pouco também eu
fui mostrando aos alunos que o lula era
um professor tão competente quanto a
nada e que da mesma forma que há na área
também acreditava nas contabilidades
como diferenças complementar escapar
de constituir um mundo realmente mais
humano
eu sabia que era hora de fazer a
travessia
eu precisava
não só me despir totalmente da área mas
eu precisava vestir o louis por inteiro
eu sabia que permanecer na trincheira
implicavam no mesmo risco de morrer
vivo eu decidi renascer sem ter que
morrer aos 40 anos eu comuniquei a minha
família e os meus família aos meus
amigos de que a partir daquele momento
eu viver em paz com a minha guerra
ninguém entendeu nada sabe por que pôs
invisíveis até as batalhas são
invisíveis
foi aí que entra o professor pesquisador
eu passei a pesquisar sobre o processo
de transgenia os tratamentos
acompanhamento médico acompanhamento
psicológico
quanto mais eu pesquisava mais louis
pulava dentro de mim
foi então que aos 45 anos
eu dei início ao processo de
transformação e comuniquei à
universidade de que em breve o professor
louis estaria substituindo a professora
na área também mas o universo é muito
caprichoso em julho de 2017 eu sou
convocado a assumir a docência e
universidade pública no sul do estado
era hora de me despedir da universidade
que me consagrou com o professor
universitário
pra isso eu escolhi agendar um café com
uma das pessoas mais caras na
universidade pra mim
membro da alta administração e durante
nossa conversa fui surpreendido
ele me pergunta como como está o
tratamento como a sua esposa está se
sentindo meio embaralhado eu sentia
necessidade de narrar a ele como cheguei
ao tratamento
num gesto sutil e gentil e liminha cena
que é desnecessária a minha
justificativa eu que tanto me
justifiquei nessa vida e ele me pergunta
como você está e eu digo em paz com a
minha guerra e ele pede pra mim levantes
ficou de pé frente a frente a ele e ele
disse pra mim como devo traçado a partir
de hoje como você vai se chamar eu digo
eu vou me chamar
louis ele me estendi a mão limites
me despeço da minha amiga nada e saúdo o
meu amigo louis e me deu um abraço
fraterno
naquele momento eu me senti acolhido e
reconhecido como louis
para finalizar ele me pede louis
nunca perder a ternura não se deixem de
acontecer pelo universo masculino
os homens estão sempre em guerra
abençoado eu me preparo para retornar
para a cidade onde passei minha infância
e adolescência onde o louis foi educado
para ser a nada e agora retorna
definitivamente
louis nossa isso me deu muito medo mas
muito me deram muitas mudanças ao mesmo
tempo agora
mas eu lembrei da minha avó quando a
vida me punha em situações de medo a
minha avó costumava dizer
a vida é feita para quem tem coragem e
deixa que falha
as pessoas precisam gastar saliva para
não engasgar essa velhinha era boa
agarrado a essas belas dentre outras
apoiado pelo amor genuíno da minha
esposa que sempre viu como louis pelo
amor incondicional do meu irmão a merlin
de quem toma de empréstimo segundo nome
contando com meu anjo encarnado
minha mãe passa eu fui faz a travessia
para fazer essa travessia não foi nada
fácil
foram momentos muito desafiadores
permitam-me compartilhar um momento
anterior à travessia quando eu
travestido de na área travestido de
mulher achava que estava enganando todo
mundo
certa feita eu me dirigi para o
anfiteatro da universidade para
participar como professor paraninfo de
uma formatura trajando um longo azul
cumprido com as portas abertas
você consegue imaginar é é a e com os
cabelos raspados porque até então era a
forma do luis se expressar nos postos de
cabelo quando passa um menininho por mim
me olha
e olha para cima e olha e ele diz assim
pai pai olha eu nunca vi um homem
vestido de mulher
gente naquele instante eu me sentir
reconhecido é o feliz e eu estou vivo
esse mimimi fio após sair da trincheira
percebendo que eu travei em busca de mim
mesmo intensas batalhas intensas
batalhas
dentre elas eu fui elaborando
estratégias de sobrevivência
eu vou compartilhar uma delas as pessoas
costumavam reparar
quando eu ea minha esposa andávamos mãos
dadas na rua é que ele os olhares
repreensivo sve giants eram meus velhos
conhecidos e eu tive uma idéia eu pensei
agora com uma pessoa nos olhar assim eu
vou cumprimentá lá efusivamente como se
fosse minha amiga íntima entende como se
o conhecesse a pessoa nos olhava e eu
fazia isso
a gente era como dizer assim eu sei o
que você fez no verão passado você não
lembra tudo bem mas se eu eu estava lá a
pessoa perde o chão ela procurava
fronteira trincheira eu não sei mas nós
nos divertimos muito com isso
muito com isso
nos 45 anos em que eu passei
entrincheirado
eu perdi mais do que ganhei eu comemorei
empates e trevas e eu aprendi o quanto é
importante comemorar em parte sim trevas
eu saio da trincheira acenando a
bandeira branca da reconciliação entre
meu corpo físico meu corpo psíquico e é
com imensa alegria qual bbb cida de paz
que eu digo pra vocês sim eu sou o louis
eu sou um homem trânsito estou em paz
com a minha guerra fiquem tranquilos a
essência não muda como diria aristóteles
o que muda é a forma a essência do louis
é anamara mas a forma do louis não é a
nar sabe quando eu começo a me dar conta
pelo está incorporando quando eu saio do
hospital depois de passar uma noite
inteira da cadeirinha da humildade que o
sus tem umas cadeiras da humildade
cuidando da minha avó
acessando a rampa de saída do hospital
eu sinto meu corpo leve solto meus
joelhos não precisam mais se
cumprimentar
basta dizer e aí beleza quando eu desço
a rampa eu me emociono eu olho pra mim
nós eu louis se incorporando pouco a
pouco o processo de construção da
identidade é uma relação dialética entre
o individual eo coletivo
por isso eu conto com vocês e que a boa
vontade que habita cada um de nós possa
interrogar a nossa humanidade e nos
tornar mais humanos capazes de nos
reconhecermos uns nos outros
mirem vejo eu sou tão humano quanto
qualquer um de vocês meus olhos cabem
nos olhos de cada um de vocês e agora o
que ainda questiona a humanidade de
vocês
acaso é a minha humanidade
[Aplausos]